The gaps intro diet is basically an ancestral diet on steroids.
The pillars being tons of homemade bone broth,
tons of regenerative meat,
very few vegetables, only non starchy,
and tons of fermented foods.
So, to put it plainly,
I'm eating a ton of soup. And when I say the cravings are real,
I mean the cravings are real.
I just want cake. Before you diagnose me with orthorexia,
the purpose behind me doing this diet
is to heal and seal my gut lining
and repopulate my gut microbiome with beneficial microbes.
One way I'm doing that is by drinking liquid whey
that I made from kefir because it's packed full of probiotics.
And I'm trying to hit as many micronutrients as I possibly can
by remineralizing my water,
taking my organ supplements,
incorporating shilajit in my ginger gelatin gummies
that I've been eating between my meals.
And let me tell you, after two weeks of eating this way,
the biggest things that I noticed
are that my mood has improved significantly
and that my brain is functioning so much better.
So I'm just gonna keep
intuitively
eating this way until I feel like incorporating more foods.